hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
si.l1-3.14.2 provide protection from
malicious code at designated locations
within organizational systems
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone frustrated sad
and you're just down in the dumps
I can understand why because if you're
trying to understand all this cmmc dfars
and nist sp80171 compliance stuff and
you've got this massive workload on you
and the world is coming down and
crushing you
well
I've got great news because you have
found your home here in on-call
compliance Solutions with us where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
Don the cape and jump into action baby
uh I love this control all right late in
the SSO or SSP uh it's nice to have a
few controls that are just plain easy to
answer right a little breath of fresh
air if you will in this case what we're
asking for is evidence of where you have
malicious code detection here's two of
the most obvious and you might even
possibly have some more but anti-virus
on the computers and servers is one and
another is likely going to be your
firewall as most firewalls these days
that are at least business class have an
integrated anti-virus and malicious code
scanning component to them again we
highly uh encourage businesses handling
cui to invest some good money in the
right firewall as is a huge protection
mechanism to the organization can't find
an affordable or right size fit firewall
give us a call we're happy to help we've
deployed thousands of firewalls have a
lot of experience our team is always
happy to share or even have us manage
the firewalls for you again we're full
service but you know if you've just got
a question about a firewall and
compliance call us up hit us up no not
there's no charge we never charge for
our first phone call like we're not like
that call us up we're just out here
trying to help you guys stay safe and if
you decide you want us to manage your
stuff or you want to buy a firewall from
us cool we can handle that too whatever
you guys need we're here for you to help
protect our country all right let's see
what the assessors are looking for on
this one
you're looking for one determine if
designated locations for malicious code
protection are identified uh again if
this was implemented we'd say hey
they're identified within the SSP and
system Baseline configuration and
network inventory documentation
second assessment Point determinative
protection for malicious code at
designated locations is provided is it
provided once identified two is provided
uh again we're going to say hey it's
implemented via the organizational
firewalls and endpoint Management
Solutions and again you know maybe we're
even blocking off a further step with a
secure data environment or something
like that so again pretty easy to answer
this one like I said it's an easy
control and late in the game it's kind
of nice to have that once in a while now
uh if you still have 108 controls left
to go after this one then the good news
is at on-call we can cut that 6 to 18
months worth of work down into about two
to three days for most companies we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this D fars nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day baby
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliances your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com
and you know if you've been watching our
videos forever and you haven't actually
gone to that website you gotta go all
right and you know what if you want to
find out exactly how we help our clients
in two to three days if you want to see
our exact process all you got to do go
to that website CMC complianceeekers.com
check out the menu somewhere on one of
those menus there's basically this free
training two to three days and we'll
literally walk you through every single
step of our process it's brilliant it's
super easy uh and again it's a live
presentation so we do it a bunch of
times every week and it's just the
coolest thing to sit through because
it'll give you a way better idea of how
this should be done and it'll even tell
you a little bit about our story which I
think is a really cool story so visit
cmmc compliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now and if you love the content
we're putting out there for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button we're even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance starts roll it out I until
the next supplies tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there and hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]
foreign